hi everyone
this is professor mdas science and today
i want to talk about
even and odd operators in another one of
our videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
even operators are operators that
commute with the parity operator this
means that the eigenstate of an even
operator can always be chosen to be
even or odd states we care about this
because the hamiltonians of many systems
happen to be
even operators from the quantum harmonic
oscillator to the hydrogen atom this is
really helpful because we know straight
away
that the eigenstate of an even
hamiltonian must be even or odd states
dramatically simplifying the
calculations by contrast to even
operators
odd operators anticommute with the
parity operator we'll also study some of
their properties
but for our purposes they're not that
interesting let's go
let's start with a refresher on the
parity operator but for the full details
you should check out the companion video
the parity operator pi is defined by its
action on the position eigenstate r
giving a new position eigenstate minus r
from a physical point of view the parity
operator reflects the system about the
origin of coordinates
and as such it is also called the space
inversion operator
we can analogously define the parity
operator by its action on momentum
eigenstates
which are also inverted in terms of wave
functions
if we start with the position wave
function psi of r
then the application of the parity
operator gives the wave function
psi of minus r and similarly for the
momentum wave functions
the key properties of the parity
operator are that it's involutary
hermitian and as a result it is also
unitary
we also found that the parity operator
based this eigenvalue equation
which means that it has two possible
eigenvalues the first is plus one
and the corresponding eigenstate is
called an even state
and the second is minus one and the
corresponding eigenstate is called an
odd state a state that is either even or
odd
is called the state of definite parity
finally we defined two projection
operators p plus
and p minus these projectors act on an
arbitrary state to generate a new state
that is an
even or not state so they allow us to
generate eigenstate of the parity
operator starting from any state
so this is it for our refresher these
definitions and properties should be
familiar from the companion video on the
parity operator
and we'll use them throughout today so
if you haven't seen the companion video
yet
i recommend that you check that out
before you continue with this video
these properties that we've just
discussed relate to how the piety
operator acts on quantum states
what we'll do today is to explore the
interplay between the piety operator
and other operators
let's start with even operators which we
label
a plus we define an even operator as an
operator that commutes with the parity
operator
this definition is often restated in a
somewhat different form
that will now derive let's rewrite the
commutation condition as a
plus pi equals pi a plus
we can now multiply with the parity
operator from the right on both sides of
the equation to get this
as the parity operator is involutary
then pi squared here
is equal to the identity which means
that we end up with a plus
equal to pi a plus pi this expression is
an alternative definition
of an even operator a plus
you'll also remember from the video on
unitary operators
that this equation simply shows the
unitary transformation of the operator a
plus
and all it's saying is that an even
operator is one that does not change
under unitary transformation provided by
the parity operator
okay so this is the definition of an
even operator
but why do we care about even operators
in the first place
the key is that even operators commute
with the parity operator
so from the video on compatible
observables we know that this means that
we can
always find a common set of eigenstates
for these two operators
this means that the eigenstates of even
operators
are states of well-defined parity in
other words they are either even
or odd states to see this
let's set up the scene by writing down
the eigenvalue equation for an even
operator a plus
let's next create two new states lambda
plus minus
by applying the projectors p plus minus
onto the lambda states
due to the properties of these
projection operators we know that these
states are such
that they are eigen states of the parity
operator
let's pause for a moment to make sure
that we understand this
we've started with the lambda here that
are eigenstates of an even operator a
plus
we have then generated two new states
lambda plus and lambda minus here
that are eigenstates of the parity
operator
what we need to do to complete the proof
is to show that these new states lambda
plus and lambda minus are actually still
eigen state of the operator a plus
for clarity we'll assume for now that
lambda is a non-degenerate eigenvalue
and come back to the assumption in a
moment let's consider the action of a
plus
on the parity eigen states rewriting the
lambda plus minus states in terms of the
projection operators we get this
to make progress we need to consider the
commutator of a plus with the projection
operators
using the definition of the projection
operators we get this
a plus trivially commutes with the
identity operator
and by definition it also commute with
the parity operator so that the
commutator here vanishes
using this result we can reorder the
expression above to p
plus minus a plus lambda
this is the eigenvalue equation for a
plus and we end up with
lambda p plus minus lambda
finally we can rewrite this as lambda
times the parity eigenstates
overall a plus acting on this parity
eigenstates
gives lambda times the parity
eigenstates again
this means that as promised the parity
eigenstates are also eigenstates of a
plus
and their eigenvalue in this case is
lambda overall this implies that the
eigenstates of an even operator have
definite parity
they are either even or odd states
if lambda were non-degenerate then the
eigenstate associated with a given
degenerate lambda may not have a
definite parity to start with
however we know from the video on
compatible observables that it's always
possible to apply a transformation
within this degenerate subspace to
obtain a new set of eigenstates of a
plus that are also eigenstates of pi
so that they do have a definite parity
now that we understand even operators we
next consider what are called
odd operators labeled by a minus
we define a node operator as an operator
that anticommutes with the parity
operator
remember that the anticommutator of two
operators b and c
is simply defined like this
just like in the case of even operators
this definition of odd operators is
often stated in a somewhat different
form
to see it let's rewrite the
anti-commutation condition as
a minus pi equals minus pi a minus
multiplying with pi from the right we
get this
and as pi squared is equal to the
identity we get this
so this is the alternative expression
for the definition of an odd operator a
minus
as an odd operator does not commute with
the parity operator then in general they
don't share a common set of eigenstates
this means that unlike the eigenstate of
even operators the eigenstates of odd
operators don't have a definite parity
in general they aren't even or odd
states
let's take a step back for a second
before we proceed to make sure that we
are happy with all these even and odd
things that we've been discussing
when we have an even operator which is
an operator that commutes with the
parity operator
or equivalently a base this relation
then its eigenstates must be either
even states or odd states
which means that there are also
eigenstates of the parity operator
another way of saying this is that the
eigenstates have a definite parity
when we have an odd operator which is an
operator that anti-commutes with the
parity operator
or equivalently obese this relation then
its eigen states have
no definite parity which means that they
aren't in general even or odd states
so we use the words even and odds to
describe two types of objects
operators and states and we must make
sure we don't confuse these terms
and i do realize that it is extremely
easy to get confused when you first
learn about this even autonomous
enclosure
this slide summarizes what you have to
remember about what we mean in each case
in many important physical systems the
operators that we have are powers of
even or odd operators and we'll see a
few examples of this later on in this
video
but before we do that let's explore the
parity properties of the powers of
operators
let's start with even operators which
are defined by this expression up here
using the right hand side we construct
the quantity pi
a plus to the power n pi
we next insert identity operators
between every pair of a plus operators
in the power like this
using the involuntary property of the
parity operator we can rewrite this
in terms of parity operators
as a plus is an even operator then each
of these factors
is equal to a plus and that we have a
total of n
such factors we end up with a plus to
the power
n this means that pi a plus to the power
n
pi is equal to a plus to the power n
this is the defining property of an even
operator so any power of an even
operator is itself
an even operator let's now turn to odd
operators whose definition is up here
in this case we built the quantity pi a
minus to the power n
pi we expand it as we did before to
obtain this
as a minus is an odd operator in this
case each of these terms
gives minus a minus
we still have n factors like before so
we get a minus to the power n
and then each term contributes a factor
of minus 1 so we also get -1 to the
power n
what does this mean for an odd operator
a minus
then a minus to the power n is still an
odd operator
if n is odd but a minus to the power
n becomes an even operator for n even
now that we understand the parities of
the powers of even and dot operators as
shown here
we actually have all the building blocks
to understand the parities of
general functions of even and dot
operators
to do so we first need a reminder about
functions of operators
consider a general function f of x and
write it as a power series
then we define the function f of a
general operator a
through the same power series
at this point you may wonder why we use
such a definition the reason of course
is that in a power series
operators only feature as powers and we
know how to calculate powers of
operators we simply apply the operator
sequentially
as an example the operator e to the
power a
is given by this power series using the
standard result of the power series of
an exponential function
and these are the first few terms of the
series spelled out
you can now see that we can straight
away use the results we just derived
about the powers of even and dot
operators to understand the properties
of general functions of operators
let's start with even operators which is
found up here
that any power n of an even operator is
itself an even operator
this means that any function of an even
operator is itself an even operator
because it can be written as powers of
even operators
let's now turn to odd operators in this
case the situation is different
because we found up here that powers of
odd operators can be either even
or odd operators depending on whether
the power n is an even or not number
the power series of an arbitrary
function f will in general have both
even and odd powers which means that a
function of a node operator has no
definite parity
however there are two special cases if
the function
f itself is an even function then the
power series only contains
even powers and this implies that the
corresponding function of a node
operator
will be even similarly if the function
f itself is an odd function then the
power series only contains
odd powers implying that the
corresponding function of a node
operator
will be odd
up to this point the results we've been
discussing about even and odd operators
may seem somewhat abstract
however they are extremely useful
because many important operators in
quantum mechanics happen to be
either even or odd operators as an
example today i will only discuss the
position
momentum and a few examples of energy
operators but you can then use the same
strategy for
any other operator that you encounter
let's start with the one-dimensional
position operator x
whose eigenvalue equation is this i want
to show that the position operator is an
odd operator and to do that we first
consider pi
x acting on an eigenstate of x using the
eigenvalue equation of x
we get this the parity operator now
reverses the sign of the x eigenstate
and we end up with this let's now
consider the reverse product
x pi acting on x the parity operator
reverses the sign of a position i can
state
and we get this we can now use the
eigenvalue equation for x
and we end up with this adding these two
equations
we get this
this here is just the anticommutator of
x and pi
and thus this equation is true for an
arbitrary basis state x then we can
conclude that the anti-commutator itself
must vanish
we could repeat the same procedure for
the y and z operators reaching the same
conclusion
so that overall we find that the
position operator r
is indeed an odd operator
for the momentum operator we can use an
analogous strategy to conclude that it
is
also an odd operator
putting this together we see that both
position and momentum operators are odd
operators
now this is a neat result but ultimately
not that useful in itself
because it is even operators that
commute with the parity operator and
therefore have eigenstates with definite
parity
but as you may already suspect very
often we're not interested in the
position and momentum operators directly
but in some function of these operators
and this is what i want to look at next
the key operator to understand the
quantum system is the hamiltonian
operator
which is the operator associated with
the total energy and is also the
operator that features in the
schrodinger equation and therefore
controls the time evolution of the
system
a general hamiltonian of a one particle
system has two terms
the first is the kinetic energy which
depends on the momentum squared
and the second is the potential energy
which in many systems is a position
dependent potential
let's dissect this starting with the
kinetic energy
we've just argued that the momentum
operator is an odd operator
as the kinetic energy is proportional to
the momentum operator squared
then the kinetic energy is an even
operator and it is given by an
even power of an odd operator
let's now move to the potential energy
the position operator is
also a nod operator but in this case the
potential energy is simply a general
function v of the position
and the general function of the node
operator has no definite parity
so for general operators the hamiltonian
has no definite parity
because of the potential energy part
however there is an exception
we saw that in the special case when the
function of an odd operator is an even
function
then the corresponding operator is
itself an even operator
this means that if the potential energy
of a system is described by an even
function
then the potential energy is an even
operator in this special case the full
hamiltonian
will then be even because both kinetic
and potential energies will be even
okay so this is one of the highlights of
this video for
even potentials the hamiltonian is
overall
an even operator this is extremely
important because it means that when we
have an even potential
we already know what sort of solutions
to expect before we do any maths
the energy eigenstates have to be either
even or odd states
such insight can be really helpful in
simplifying the solution
of problems in quantum mechanics
to finish i just want to give you two
examples of even potentials to
demonstrate that indeed their
eigenstates have a definite parity
we'll work in the position
representation in terms of wave
functions because it is very easy to
think about position dependent
potentials in the position basis
the first one is the infinite square
well potential
and for full details you can find our
video on this potential link in the
description
let's first set up a pair of coordinate
axes
is a diagram of the potential which is 0
between minus a over 2 and a over 2
and infinite outside
mathematically we can write it like this
you can very clearly see from both the
diagram and the mathematical expression
that the potential is described by an
even function
so the overall hamiltonian is even we
then expect the eigenstates to have
definite parity
and indeed in the detailed video on the
infinite square well we find that the
eigenstates
psi are labeled by positive integers n
and that they are proportional to a
cosine
for odd n and proportional to a sine
for even n outside well the wave
function vanishes
as expected we obtain states of fixed
parity even states described by a cosine
and odd state described by a sign
here i have plots for the six lowest
energy eigenstates of the infinite
square well
i'm not including dimensions on the axis
because all we want to focus on
are the parity properties of the
eigenfunctions
the first one here corresponds to the
ground state labeled by n equals 1
and is clearly an even state the second
one corresponds to n equals 2
and is clearly an odd state the n equals
3
and n equals five eigenstates are also
even states
and the n equals four and n equals six
states are odd states
before moving on to the next example i
should point out that you will very
often encounter the infinite square well
potential with a different
origin where the zero of the potential
is between zero
and a in this case the potential is
clearly not
an even function so the hamiltonian will
not be even and the eigenstate will not
have definite parity
although many textbooks use this
potential from 0 to a and you can indeed
solve it to determine the corresponding
eigen states
i think using this symmetric potential
up here is much more insightful
because it exploits the inversion
symmetry present in the system
the second and final example i want to
look at is the quantum harmonic
oscillator
and again for full details you can find
our videos on this potential link in the
description
let's set up a pair of axes again this
is the diagram of the potential
its mathematical form simply shows the
quadratic dependent on the displacement
and again you can see from both the
diagram and the mathematical expression
that the potential is described by an
even function
so the overall hamiltonian is again even
the eigen states should have definite
parity
and indeed in the detailed video on the
quantum harmonic oscillator eigenstates
we find that the eigenstates are labeled
by
psi n of x where n is a non-negative
integer
and are equal to this pre-factor
a hermite polynomial of order n
and a gaussian these functions here
the hermit polynomials are even for even
n and od for odd n this is just a
gaussian
which is an even function so overall the
eigenstates of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
are even for even n and alt for odd n
again as expected they have definite
parity
finally here i have plot for the sixth
lowest energy eigenstate of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
the eigenstates 0 2 and 4
are clearly even functions while 1
3 and 5 are odd functions
we've just seen a few examples of even
hamiltonians and their even and old
eigenstates
you can check out other systems which
also have even hamiltonians for example
the hydrogen atom and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe